we don't find this really distracting
oml so probably really unnecessary
that's it I'm sorry sir no there are so
many free ones down there no we need to
be right next to I just want you to know
my arm day was yesterday super nervous
that people can hear that I'm listening
to cast the music is it audible you're
really attractive and I don't want you
to see me like this right now I just
want you to know that I respect you and
I respect all women I don't need to look
at you I just I can't it's hard it's
hard not to moist right is it this is
not bothering anyone else I'm sorry
how are you so open and uninhibited
right now because you're spreading Eagle
and if I could do that I mean I'd be I
can't control my eyes from not looking I
mean you're open for a shot right now
that hasn't even cross your mind
there are butts everywhere and the
clothing shows the bus what's your name
Tammy Tammy Tammy everyone so much
better thank you
gyms are hard gyms are tough for me I
actually just I should just work out at
home
because maybe deference
this is not a park bench
this is a place where people work out
this is a gymnasium I would like to do
an exercise here please